i ain't a dog like that's another [ __ ]
like of course like i hate to say them
nigga's name because everybody said but
you gotta give credit when dude like you
gotta speak when you talk to him you
gotta say wayne you gotta say biggie you
gotta say pop you gotta say hope yeah
you gotta say ho too you know those are
the ones that are like yes it just they
give you that's why i don't like saying
them so much but it's like now you would
rather have a listening to the evening
like come on now now they knew jay-z was
that hundred bars awesome cool the only
goddamn true i ain't talking that [ __ ]
on me he was that's what's crazy
wayne's verse got overlooked on that
record wayne was talking that [ __ ] on
her lane cause wayne is right he
influenced all this [ __ ] going on say
wayne wayne make a [ __ ] think
about two weeks what the [ __ ] he was
trying to say like what was he really
like getting it like here hey you like
what the [ __ ] was he saying it'd take
you that long to think about it what is
your favorite lil wayne album uh
favorite lil wayne me personally i like
the carter one
actually
to me it's carter one or two i like the
quarter one
the first quarter that's that's [ __ ]
just that birdman junior
birdman junior
birdman g i miss my dog miss my dog come
now what's the other song that i don't
know what do you say uh i'm gonna bounce
up my own click i'm my own [ __ ] i will
say [ __ ] you but go and get your own
dick
this this this is the caller ladies and
gentlemen do you remember um
do you remember the
when when uh the miss my dogs there was
like footage that back then went viral
however went viral was like myspace or
twitter or something of like all of the
hot boys i don't know if bg was there i
don't know if this is before bg went to
prison but little wayne performed that
song with juvenile and uh and i i i'm
trying to think i ain't seen it there
was something so look it up yeah it's
online there was like a point in time
where at least juvie was there when
wayne did that record and that record's
so crazy if you think about like then he
said he missed his dog as if they were
dead but they not dead he was just
saying he just missing like just them
being around them
yeah this [ __ ] was around
juveniles since he was a child yeah
yeah carter once i respect that you know
what the one thing about wayne is that
i just feel like after
no ceilings which is in 09
i just never could really rock with any
of his projects after that was it i just
wasn't a fan of carter iv i didn't think
it was great there were some cool
singles
you're probably getting caught up in the
you gotta like if you're a diehard fan
you're gonna be a die-hard fan of course
you're gonna be biased at the same time
but then again you know
like i am not a human being and the
revolver when he was doing the rock [ __ ]
it just was saying wayne being why he
not playing into the sound what's going
on right now carter five was like
two discs and
that was recently you know it was that
feels i hope the carter six is
man he's still laying i got one wayne
just going stupid he's still wayne he
still ain't he's still i just heard some
[ __ ] with him and change got going on uh
i'll tell you what probably my favorite
lil wayne project since no ceilings the
first no ceilings is probably the two
chains wayne project that [ __ ] was slept
on bro somehow i think they can have
something going on somehow when those
collab albums happen because most of the
time each artist is on their own label
they never get the the rightful push and
they always fly under the [ __ ] radar
like think about the wayne and two
chains [ __ ] there were some
hits on like that [ __ ] was crazy but
they were both i just feel like people
just probably don't because he ain't
been consistent in the sense of just
been dropping music some people
and then he went through the whole like
you know you try yeah he was trying to
get off uh he was trying to get i mean
there was that whole era of the free
weezy era you know what i'm saying so